[Music]
in gift complaining news submitted by a
good kid maad city a man was fired for
complaining about his company's holiday
gifts that's a funny reason to get fired
I gotta know how hard these gifts up I
got a flashlight from my in-laws for
Christmas pretty bad well what kind
though is it the comics flashlight the
[ __ ] is a high-powered as flashlight for
camping money little because you do it a
lot honey how about two men lumen
[ __ ] love flashlights it's got the
light of day coming on soon I want to do
cuz there's a his parents watch this
they're not your parents I'll do it out
of respect to him but maybe they got
this give you the roasting them more
than I was pleased with her they
probably got it as a gift they're like
this is some [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we
forgot to get Nicky something no he has
the gift receipt for Walmart
if only listen my parents love [ __ ] that
you don't need you know how you think of
that like when you're walking down the
aisle a flashlight is so useful for you
for Nicky it's not just as fun it's a
spotlight handcannon
[ __ ] there's no reason why she needs
[ __ ] isn't really bright really it's
like this big and like yeah it's a good
they live in the boondocks we live in a
city that has lights everywhere you
could probably use it for doing your
you're vlogging adventures bar Oh
driller even when our lights are out
there's so much street light ambient
[ __ ] I can see in my house top you know
the guy I would never go camping if
there's no shower damn straight you are
war shower thank you what about wet
wipes it's not gonna see I'm gonna wash
my hair I have to be able wash my hair
what hair what's left of it came in too
late feels fresh with alcohol I'm good
that's the rule cuz you dig up there
with so well yeah you just told this you
[ __ ] wash your clothes while you're
wearing it in the shower we get it
he watches his [ __ ] in the ocean no
these gifts how bad were they okay well
before I tell you the news
first I want to tell you the entire
background story
context and want that crazy no okay so
this company has offices in all of North
America so it's like Canada the US and
Mexico and so apparently this past year
they just gave a twenty seven dollar
budget for the gift the gift box or
looking whatever that they usually do at
the end of the year for the company
twenty four dollars twenty seven dollars
oh and a random number yeah I know super
random so usually they give the same
holiday box to all three countries but
then this year because of the the the
trade laws and like you know just
getting certain food items across the
borders just more other tariffs and the
important export all our stuff yeah yeah
so so they decided to just give this
budget to the countries and like let the
country decide what to give their
employees so this Canadian man was very
upset when he received a bottle of
barbecue sauce
and a wooden barbecue scraper in
December which is not even the barbecue
season heroin it should have been maple
syrup home she should have been a
flashlight and a cake mix what did what
side did you think I was gonna be on I'm
gonna tell you that that's my kind of
gift her personal so I know we have a
lot of barbecue sauce in our fridge I
was like which one can I throw away you
like barbecue sauce long expired nice
one wait he doesn't that you throw away
expired snow and like I can't throw
expired things anymore ever since I
threw out his expired adderall or
whatever expired at all
don't expire it's thank you Joe yeah I
know but I learned that the hard way and
now I can't throw away anything expired
and this man it's like food and
different from doctors because
medication has a half-life so if it
expires
he still doesn't mind me throw away his
barbecue sauce food is another he has so
many jars of pickles listen the food is
all right listen listen so if you were
to throw away his barbecue sauce what
happens he throw well I don't know if I
throw away the wrong one like oh that
was his favorite one like is there
different is that buy another one no I
get a ghost pepper one yeah I got a
ghost pepper one very spicy very nice
well I want to know do you consume these
items after they've expired 100% no he
doesn't continue trash bag what and by
the way barbecue sauce has a lot of
sugar in Asia do and you don't like
sugar he impulse buys bad sauces and
condiments and and and jalapeno peppers
or whatever the freaking peppers are
it's so many jars of peppers and I can't
throw anything away because he yells at
me if I thought with our own therefore
it's no wonder yeah you know what it is
TIFF it's so funny cuz I have maybe five
items in the fridge and this [ __ ] buys
wilty ass [ __ ] salad don't buy
it don't buy you guys way too many
veggies and sheets we had to throw away
a whole [ __ ] trash bag of her
recently and I called myself out because
my eyeballs bought from my healthy self
but I was sick and didn't have an
appetite and couldn't eat the groceries
I called myself out oh did you call
yourself that no mom's no relationship
order today we discussed that you know
your problems in the kitchen fridge all
your [ __ ] you
Wow they're gonna have some really good
sex later that's that's for sure that's
for sure I want to [ __ ] you I tried to
[ __ ] you last night
whoa
headaches week whoops I try to help this
is why did you think you were gonna pick
Barney hey Nikki Nikki when are we going
out with me go home tonight I'm gonna
have a whole row at night stands waiting
for you uh-oh and I'm gonna have a lot
of one-night stands to bringing him back
to this story all right I like barbecue
sauce barbecue sauce so then this guy he
went on his anonymous Twitter account to
vent anonymous very specifically follows
one person himself
Cheryl followers he got zero likes like
zero anything any interaction should
have been mesquite I will read what the
caption says what kind of multi-billion
dollar company gifts it's Canadian
employees barbecue sauce as a holiday
gift yet the USA employees stuff their
faces with an actual holiday gift box
which is filled with like cookies and
jerky outside math is the best move down
to Mecca mo he like he actually tagged
the the Canadian company and the
American company he left the Mexican one
out yeah he left them makes me wanna you
didn't know what they got yeah you know
so this was this was the actual they had
a pinata filled with Gibson like you
just killing
that's tight I want the keys to the
[ __ ] speedboat a party that's tight so
what ended up happening was this guy he
forgot that way way way back
he had tweeted out a photo of himself
buying some like tickets to like WWE or
something but he didn't have his face in
it because we didn't have his
workstation so you could like they
pinpointed who it was
wow that's some investigative [ __ ] right
there really though cuz he did all the
work for them no but to even go in the
page and look like oh this guy is trash
and loves WWE but he turns his nose up
at barbecue I know right yeah yeah so
then that's a day later is when his
manager called him in and addressed him
by his anonymous weirdest tail tucked
between his [ __ ] yeah and then
he ended up saying or like telling him
to delete the tweet which he had already
done and then sometime after that that's
when the manager called him and again to
tell him that this time he had been
fired for violating the company's
standards of conduct policy he was not
offered any severance and so the company
just issued him his last paycheck he
cashed out his unused vacation days and
gave him a 750 $1 in dollars in
commission and so he says he believes he
was done very very dirty he was done
dirty he's like all that [ __ ] cuz I
don't like barbecue sauce I like you
sweet about how you didn't like barbecue
sauce like I you know you could pout
about things sometimes like I thought I
was gonna get an actual gift or whatever
you know that was worse because that was
like basically criticizing the company
for being cheap and [ __ ] up to its
employees because he says look at this
multi-billion dollar corporation that's
giving us jack [ __ ] while everyone else
is getting better she he knew they're
getting $27 gift no you didn't know that
we didn't know that you didn't know what
he saw the packages that the American
company was dating but he didn't know
that it was actually the Canadian branch
that [ __ ] them or would rather get a
kiddy card for $27 than barbecue sauces
spatula
I like savory a lot of people like sweet
I like savory barbecue sauce is right up
my alley
barbecue sauces has tons of show you're
in it you [ __ ] dumbass
it's made with brown sugar and ketchup
but it's it's not sweet I don't
oh it's not a ghost pepper I get ghost
[ __ ] pepper barbecue sauce it is why
doesn't it taste like ghost pepper then
why does it taste like pure goes I'm a
ghost pepper barbecue sauce holding my
dick and [ __ ] you with it later you just
put it in a vagina not on your dual-pane
that was my usual delivery system so I
had to rethink that yeah you [ __ ] up
so this is before any employees see he
says he's worked at the company for six
years and now being fired he with the
barbecue sauces this is what I [ __ ]
[ __ ] funny guy do to make him bring it
he must not have been an asset to the
company at all I mean he sounds like an
entitled [ __ ] to me
the general manager cuz if you're if you
straight [ __ ] kill it yeah the next
person above you who loves you will
overlook a ton of [ __ ] they were just
looking for something yeah they're just
waiting he was it was not an asset at
all yeah so an employee or what is it
employee like lawyer employer oh yeah
attorney yeah
voice right there eh Parker like a
lawyer or whatever so he so they they
have said that he possibly could have a
legal case here because of the fact that
they didn't offer him severance which
they're required to in Canada so that's
the thing and so they have admitted
wrongful dismissal
that the way he sees it is that the
company has it all because the cup the
CEO ended up saying that cooler heads
did not prevail in this whole thing but
he's not gonna double he's not gonna
question what that branch did so he does
kind of stand by it
dude that's crazy it just shows you how
polite they are up there in Canada for
him to be like oh I don't like this
barbecue sauce that's crazy [ __ ] you
said you tweeted some crazy [ __ ]
Canadians have a Minnesota and I like
yeah they say oi know this nothing toss
strange to you literally so stupid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]